lundi deux des cent des deux journées
aujourd'hui on va commencer la semaine
par faire un petit peu de sport parce
que mine de rien il va bien falloir
s'entretenir après tout ce que j'ai de
loot sonné pendant cette période
ça te va mieux tenet ont commencé la
semaine avec une séance de sport ça fait
un bien fou
maintenant c'est l'heure de partir
manger noël est fini mais on fait quand
même les achats de noël doit trouver ton
bonheur pas mal ça on a cherché le
suédois bon sinon tu as bien manger oui
super ne montrent pas vous avez ça est
un tout petit mois exactement la même
qu'est ce qui est pire que faire les
courses avec sa femme se trouvait ce que
tu voulais le début de l'année vous le
savez c'est moment idéal pour souhaiter
c'est de tout le monde s'y colle on
souhaite l'aider à ses proches à sa
famille à ses amis à sa mémé à tout le
monde
le chef de l'état souhaite ses voeux la
région le département et les mairies
également et justement aujourd'hui je
voulais vous parler des voeux de la
mairie de clermont ferrand qui sont il
faut le dire un petit peu surprenant
avant toute chose je vous mets réseau
ici je parle pas de politique je suis
pas partisan je n'ai aucun parti pris ni
pour la droite ni pour la gauche juste
parler des faits et les faits sont super
intéressant j'ai aucun problème avec la
ville de clermont ferrand avec le maire
olivier bianchi ni avec personne
donc c'est absolument pas un règlement
de comptes olivier bianchi qu'il nouveau
maire de clermont ferrand veut vraiment
donner un coup de tonus à la ville ça
c'est top
le slogan c'est vivre intensément ils
veulent vraiment donner un coup de main
un coup de jeune et vraiment redynamiser
la ville et montrer les atouts de cette
ville ce qui me paraît complètement
normal et c'est autour de 4 grands
atouts de la ville qu'ils ont vraiment
travaillé autour cette campagne le sport
avec l'asn le festival international de
courts métrages michelin et les facultés
de la ville quatre grands points sur
lesquels il faut communiquer ils ont dû
faire un brainstorming fatalement comme
en faisant tous les services de com
qu'est-ce qu'on va bien pouvoir faire
pour donner une image jeune alors l'idée
qui a ressorti ses le second degré
personnellement je suis un très grand
fan du second 3e 4e de tous les degrés
d'humour quand on est une municipalité
c'est hyper délicat à nani et il ya un
point en particulier car retenu mon
attention
voilà l'objet du délit vivre ici c'est
prendre le risque de vous faire plaquer
d'être pris de court de perdre vos
facultés de vous faire rouler clermont
ferrand vivre intensément
pourquoi pas c'est l'humour c'est vrai
que c'est rigolo c'est décalé il ya un
message jeune et dynamique
mais le problème d'une conne comme ça si
vous vous adressez à l'ensemble de vos
administrés des jeunes qui sont
normalement plus sensibles à ce type
d'humour mais aussi aux personnes de 70
ans 60 ans 81 50 ans à tout le monde aux
gens qui sont plus aisées dans la vie
aux gens qui le sont moins a tout le
monde est alors avoir un message ni pour
tout le monde c'est extrêmement
compliqué c'est pour ça que les
communications règles générales pour les
administrations sont toujours très
institutionnalisée c'est relativement
chien sans saveur mais personne n'a
jamais rien à dire là ils ont vraiment
voulu marquer un grand coup et je peux
dire qu'ils ont pas loupé leur cours
pour moi ce qui est délicat dans vous
faire plaquer l'asm bon salarié sert
plaque est éventuellement si vous vous
êtes fait larguer 31 décembre je peux
comprendre que ça vous embête
mais bon sinon il ya globalement rien à
dire là dessus être pris de court court
métrage c'est rigolo effectivement voilà
perdre vos facultés bon en règle
générale en tout cas la faculté les gens
vont pas devenir des abrutis ceux qui
vont pas clé un peu là dessus je trouve
ça toujours délicat en règle générale
quand on voit la fin qu'on va passer
facultés et aux rudes que les facultés
de clermont ferrand sont pas des
facultés d'idiot donc
jusque là tout va bien d'autant plus que
les pôles d'excellence mais bon c'est
pas le sujet du jour
par contre que je trouve vraiment
étonnant c'est vous faire rouler et pour
cause gardez toujours mais la fiche en
gros ça je trouve ça hyper délicat pour
la simple et bonne raison c'est qu'en
2016 la ville de clermont ferrand a
augmenté la part municipale des impôts
locaux taxe foncière taxe d'habitation
de 9%
et c'est en ça que c'est compliqué je
imaginer que les gens qui ont voté pour
olivier bianchi et pour son équipe se
sont a dit tiens on va élire le maire et
il va nous mettre des augmentations 9%
alors effectivement il ya l'état des
finances de la ville il ya une situation
en instant t il ya une politique
économique à mener je peux absolument
pas juger de ça et je m'en garderais
franchement par contre ce qui est
compliqué c'est que lorsque vous veillez
d'augmenter les impôts de 9 % d'une
ville comme celle de clermont ferrand et
que les voeux
l'année d'après sont en vente lundi
ferrand vous risquez de vous faire
rouler alors même si fatalement c'est de
l'humour sur michelin et qu'on veut
vraiment montrer les points attractif en
maniant le second degré pour beaucoup de
personnes
ça reste quand même hyper délicat et
c'est en ça qui est un vrai bad buzz là
dessus alors soit le service com de la
ville n'a pas du tout mesurer le risque
là dessus et la façon dont les
administrés pour lui prend soin ils sont
dix c'est l'humour les gens vont
comprendre mais comment faire comprendre
à des dizaines de milliers de personnes
que ça c'est une blague
alors qu'ils ont vu augmenter leurs
impôts locaux ça reste quand même super
délicat donc le second degré j'adore
c'est fantastique
l'idée de dynamiser voulons faire
quelque chose de jeunes c'est une super
idée il faut continuer dans ce sens je
pense que personne ne dira le contraire
par contre augmenté les impôts la même
année et faire une com après en disant à
carmaux vous risquez de vous faire ou
et même si le maire clermont ferrand
soutien en disant c'est l'humour c'est
pour dynamiser les gens qui ne
comprennent pas ne comprennent pas le
second degré ça reste quand même hyper
délicate vis-à-vis des gens qui payent
plus d'impôts malgré tout le service com
de la ville de clermont ferrand
c'est une bonne idée ça reste quand même
très très délicat et le faire de cette
façon là je pense pas que ce soit une
bonne idée
je sais bien les liens de ses deux
jambes c'est que ce avec maman quand a
pris une petite surprise un petit livre
qui revient maison car elle y est tu
veux je te montre qu'on peut acheter
est ce que tu sais ce qui est écrit là
il est écrit caca boudin chicago
si vous balzac à kabrikha et bah c'est
un livre où il expliqué qu'un boudin n'y
a pas qu'à kaboul d'or
[Musique]